pour éviter des pénuries et des ruptures
d'approvisionnement la russie va
interdire l'exportation de plus de 200
types de marchandises jusqu'à la fin de
2022 cette interdiction vise
l'agriculture l'automobile les
technologies les télécoms les composants
électriques les wagons les conteneurs
les turbines la médecine et
l'interdiction vise aussi l'exportation
de certains types de bois vers des pays
qui sont vus en ce moment comme étant
très hostile bien sûr on en parle ce
soir avec jean-françois s'imbriquer le
pdg du conseil de l'industrie forestière
du québec bonsoir en somme ce feeling
quand on pense au bois d'oeuvre et au
bois puis aux exportations la russie
occupe la première place si je me trompe
pas c'est le premier exportateur mondial
de bois sur la planète c'est un joueur
excessivement important qui a deux tiers
de ses ventes qui sont vers la chine
regard d'un gant de mandat mais
également tout près de 25% vers l'europe
et donc ce qui amène une rareté en
europe est ce qu'il va faire monter les
prix en europe et nous a dit on du côté
du conseil de l'industrie forestière du
québec on suit ça quotidiennement oui
parce qu'il ya un effet de substitution
si le prix augmentent en europe les
européens vont cesser il faut s'y
attendre d' envoyer du bois aux états
unis pour le garder chez eux et il y
aura une demande à combler aux états
unis que nous pourrions comblé de ce
côté ci de la frontière nous pourrions à
partie le combler mais il faudra
également regarder comment est ce que
les chinois vont se comporter par
rapport aux bottes colombie britannique
donc s'ils sont satisfaits par le bois
qui vient de russie le bois de colombie
britannique il va aux états unis et du
côté de l'est du canada il pourrait y en
avoir par contre les industries c'est à
garder le bois au québec de façon
importante et on est les derniers
chiffres viennent de sortir pour le mois
de février et c'est tout près de deux
tiers du bois produit au québec qui
restent ici vous dites ça parce qu'il y
aurait un enjeu
si par exemple on devait exporter plus
de voix vers les états unis il y aurait
un enjeu dans notre notre
approvisionnement un terme en bout et je
vous dis ça parce que lyon une notion
l'effet de dire qu'il y aura une demande
excessivement forte au québec pour la
construction pour la rénovation mais
cette demande elle est également
présente aux états unis et donc les
etats-unis demandent pour le bo il n'y a
qu'un sur le marché pour le bois en
amérique du nord donc la volonté des
industriels au québec c'est de répondre
à la demande mais il ya des gens aux
états unis qui ont été là quand la
construction n'était pas présente au
québec qu'ils ont acheté donc il demande
pour avoir droit dans la dynamique et
dans ce que vous venez d'expliquer vous
avez parlé des chinois est ce qu'on
comprend ce comment réagissent les
chinoises qu'on est déjà une idée de la
réaction des choix par rapport à leurs
approvisionnements bois encore c'est
quelque chose qu'on suit de très près et
on veut également savoir si la russie
avait mis en place une barrière à
exporter des billes de bois des grumes
pour faire augmenter la transformation
locale et le est ce que ça vaut se
maintenir ça entrée en fonction au 1er
janvier est-ce que ça va se maintenir ou
est-ce que la crise faisant ils vont
exporter directement à chez nous on suit
de très près parce que ç'a un impact sur
les marchés nord américains ok on va
regarder des graphiques qu'on a préparé
juste pour bien comprendre l'industrie
votre industrie du bois et graphique
donc sur le volume exporté de bois
d'oeuvre résineux selon les pays la
ligne rouge c'est la ligne du canada
depuis l'an 2000 on voit que ça à
fluctuer un peu d'un peu pas mal là il
ya eu une remontée depuis une dizaine
d'années mais la ligne bleue que vous
voyez c'est la russie la russie a même
dépassé le canada entre exportateurs
avec ce formateur effectivement une
poignée il ya eu une politique mise en
place pour multiplié de cette ressource
l'exportation de cette ressource
tutoriel donc ça c'est pour les volumes
d'exportation quand on regarde le prix
on voit on sait que nos deux par quatre
coûter un peu plus cher depuis deux ans
avec la pandémie mais
et on comprend donc le 2 par 4 va encore
augmenter là on est en hausse
présentement on est en hausse
présentement et vous savez le prix c'est
le reflet de l'offre et de la demande
est là on est capable de venir
quantifier l'offre avec précision reste
à voir la demande vous vous parler
d'inflation est ce que les taux
d'intérêt vont monter est ce que les
gens vont restreindre leur volonté ce
qu'on lit dans les journaux c'est que
les québécois veulent construire veulent
rénover veut des maisons neuves
maintenant c'est ce qu'il faut suivre
parce que le prix c'est le reflet de la
rencontre de l'offre et de la demande ok
mais juste pour bien comprendre quel
sera l'effet ou quel serait l'effet de
la guerre en ukraine que nous vivons
présentement des restrictions sur les
exportations de bois toutes les
sanctions vient expliquer combien ça va
mal en russie dans l'économie l'effet
sur le prix de notre bois chez nous ben
écoutez si la demande est plus forte que
l'offre il faut s'attendre à ce que le
prix montent cependant le gouvernement
du québec pas en sa possession des
moyens de venir stabiliser les prix en
permettant à l'industrie d'aller
récolter le forestier en chef qui est
nommé par l'assemblée nationale pour
superviser la récolte forestière puis de
s'assurer que ce soit fait de façon
durable identifie comme un volume
d'environ 4 millions de mètres cubes qui
a été récoltée dans les dernières années
et qui pourraient être disponibles pour
venir augmenter l'offre de bois mais y
est sûr que toute action qui va
augmenter l'offre de bois disponible sur
le marché va permettre de stabiliser et
l inverse toute action gouvernementale
qui vont venir réduire l'offre aura une
là haut sur les puits pour augmenter
l'offre faut avoir la conviction que la
demande est au rendez vous l'ondé
confirme complètement la pandémie semble
se terminer les gens vont peut-être
moins fabriquer une maison peut-être
moins construire est ce que les
américains ont besoin de notre bois est
ce que la guerre aura vraiment un effet
il ya beaucoup de facteurs avant de
décider qu'on appuie sur le bouton pour
augmenter le volume de production vous
avez raison mais les québécois ont
ajusté leur façon de commander avec un
cahier et les grands constructeurs comme
en maintenant huit à dix semaines avant
et donc ça c'est un élément puis les
québécois
on a une pénurie de main d'oeuvre on a
une pénurie de logements pénurie de
bâtiments sociaux d'école et est donc à
construire donc il ya une politique
d'utilisation du bois dans la
construction
donc la demande pour le bois elle est
présent et il faut il faut répondre et
de le faire en sorte que le prix ont pu
se stabiliser
mais je vous dirai qu'ils ont également
la crise amène qu'une ouverture sur
l'europe sur différents marchés
différents produits violent et les
granules la russie envoyait deux
millions de tonnes de granulés de bois
pour répondre à la transition
énergétique européenne et la sega nul ne
sont plus là donc le volume pour le
québec pour l'est de la mairie venant
d'aller répondre ok c'est ce que nous
allons voir jean françois samray merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit